We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You may not want to waste energy or burn fossil fuels, but the deck is stacked against you. Everything is designed to just use more and more fuel.
我们获得了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马斯。你可能不想浪费能源或燃烧化石燃料，但形势对你很不利。一切的设计都只是为了消耗越来越多的燃料。
And as you'll see, Lisa Marganelli argues that design might not be the right word, but let's just say designed for now. My name is Lisa Marganelli argues that design might not be the right word, but let's just say it designed for now. My name is Lisa Marganelli, and I wrote a book called Oil on the Brain Petroleum's Long Strange Trip to Your Tank. First, a metaphor. We are on a tugboat. A couple months ago, I was at a tugboat race, and we were looking at an old tugboat from when they used to be powered by coal. And it was beautiful, it was shaped like a canoe on the bottom. And the house on top was rounded and aerodynamic. Just like it is in the Popeye cartons, it was beautiful. It was shaped like a canoe on the bottom. And the house on top was rounded and aerodynamic.
正如你将看到的，莉萨·马加内利认为“设计”可能并不是正确的词，但我们现在暂且称之为设计。我的名字是莉萨·马加内利，她认为“设计”可能并不是正确的词，但我们现在暂且称之为设计。我的名字是莉萨·马加内利，我写过一本书叫《油浸大脑：石油通往你油箱的漫长而离奇之旅》。首先，打个比方。我们在一艘拖船上。几个月前，我去参加了一场拖船比赛，我们看到了一艘过去靠燃煤驱动的旧拖船。它非常漂亮，底部形状像独木舟。上面的船舱是圆润且符合空气动力学的。就像大力水手动画里的一样，它非常漂亮，底部形状像独木舟。
Just like it is in the Popeye cartons, it was gorgeous. It was all very streamlined to slip through the water and through the air on top. But there's also a newer diesel tugboat. And the hull is relatively square-ish. I mean, it's shaped to go through the water, but things are not scooped the way they were in the other one. And the top is just straight flat pieces of steel. They don't even bother to shape them. They just skimp on all the corners.
就像它在《大力水手》动画片里一样，它太美了。它的整体线条非常流畅，以便在水中滑行，并在顶部划过空气。但这里还有一艘更新的柴油拖船。它的船体相对呈方形。我是说，它的外形是为了在水中航行，但各个部分并没有像另一艘船那样被挖空。而且顶部只是笔直平坦的钢板。他们甚至懒得去给它们塑形。他们只是在所有的角落里偷工减料。
And the reason is that when you have a coal-fired tugboat, every bit of coal that you have to put on that tugboat has to convert to power, and you want to reduce the amount of extra fuel that you need to have there. With diesel fuel, it's very easy. It's very plentiful now. It's much easier to just design the tugboat to use more fuel, to waste fuel essentially, then to shape the steel and design that tugboat to use
原因在于，当你拥有一艘燃煤拖船时，你装载到该拖船上的每一块煤都必须转化为动力，而你会希望减少你需要在那里的额外燃料量。使用柴油燃料就非常简单了。现在它非常充足。设计一艘消耗更多燃料、实质上是浪费燃料的拖船，要比塑造钢材并设计那艘能够使用的拖船
less fuel. So fuel is our expendable in our economy right now. And the whole world is designed as a big diesel square bottomed tugboat. The biggest waste of energy is the whole system. And the most wasteful component of that whole system in the US is the way we drive to and from work. The whole process of selling mortgages and selling houses over the last 15 years or so is based on this concept of drive to the qualify. So you drove as far out in the countryside as you could stand
消耗更少燃料的拖船要容易得多。因此，燃料是我们目前经济中的消耗品。整个世界就被设计成了一艘巨大的、柴油驱动的方形底部拖船。最大的能源浪费就是整个系统。而美国整个系统中浪费最严重的环节，是我们开车上下班的方式。在过去十五年左右的时间里，出售抵押贷款和出售房屋的整个过程都是基于“为符合贷款资格而开车”这一概念。所以你尽可能远地开到乡村里你所能忍受的
to the place where you could get a decent rate on a mortgage and a house with a low enough down payment that you could make that payment. And at the same time, you'd get like more square footage in your house. And what supported that was that you were gonna drive further to get into the city to do your job. And then what supported that was that there were discounts
地方，在那里你能获得体面的抵押贷款利率，并且首付足够低，使你能够还得起月供。与此同时，你还能在房子里获得更大的面积。而支撑这一切的是，你要开更远的车进城去上班。接着，支撑这一点的又是
on really big cars. So if you'd been making that trip in a small car, you might have felt a little bit unsafe, but you could buy this like, palatial car at great discount. And those big cars have horrible gas mileage, but that's not all. Everything along the way acts to burn more gas. Just stopping at a stoplight uses an enormous amount of energy. But it's not just the obstacles. Even barreling down the highway at top speed is a problem. Cars were tuned to be most efficient around 55 to 60. That's the speed the government used to test for fuel efficiency.
对大排量汽车的大幅折扣。因此，如果你开着一辆小车进行那样的出行，你可能会觉得有点不安全，但你可以以极大的折扣买到这种像宫殿一样的汽车。那些大车的油耗极其可怕，但这还不是全部。沿途的一切都在促使人们燃烧更多的汽油。仅仅是在红灯前停车就要消耗巨量的能源。但不仅是障碍物。甚至在高速公路上全速疾驰也是个问题。汽车被调校得在时速 55 到 60 英里时效率最高。那是政府用来测试燃油经济性的速度。
So they were essentially designed to be less efficient at the speeds that we really drive them because we really drive around 65 to 70. It's as if some evil genius designed a system so that we will waste gasoline. How evil is this? Yeah. It's more much more banal than evil. If someone sat down to consciously design this thing,
所以它们基本上被设计成在我们实际驾驶的速度下效率较低，因为我们实际驾驶的时速在 65 到 70 英里左右。这就像某个邪恶的天才设计了一个系统，好让我们浪费汽油。这有多邪恶？是的。这比邪恶要平庸得多。如果有人坐下来有意识地设计这个东西，
I don't know that they could do such a good job of making a mess of things. It's the tyranny of the lack of design, that tragedy of building a bad idea on a thoughtless notion on a careless plan. Another dumb thing piles on to another dumb thing and pretty soon we've got just a huge tangle of dumb all based on buying gasoline fairly cheaply. And speaking of buying gasoline cheaply, there is something designed, actually designed, to make you more comfortable with all of this when you buy gas. We don't like to be in gas stations, we feel like they're dangerous, and we don't like to be
我不知道他们能否把事情弄得这么一团糟。这就是缺乏设计的暴政，是在漫不经心的想法之上建立糟糕理念、在粗心大意的计划之上酿成悲剧。一个蠢主意叠加着另一个蠢主意，很快我们就陷入了一团巨大的愚蠢之中，而这一切都建立在以相当低廉的价格购买汽油的基础之上。说到廉价购买汽油，确实有某种东西在设计上——真正意义上的设计——旨在让你在买油时对这一切感到更加安心。我们不喜欢去加油站，我们觉得它们很危险，而且我们不喜欢
paying money for gasoline to the oil companies. And we always feel that gas is too expensive, no matter what the price is. So, gas pumps have been specifically designed to sort of diffuse that anger. So, they did some market research and they found that people have warm feelings towards ATM machines, and they had bad feelings towards gas pumps. So they redesigned the gas pumps to look a little bit more like ATM machines. So you felt like you were having sort of an intimate warm experience when you were at the gas pump as opposed to thinking about hating the oil companies. Because we want an experience in tune with our values, Even if what we're doing isn't.
把钱花在向石油公司购买汽油上。而且无论价格如何，我们总是觉得汽油太贵了。因此，加油机经过了专门设计，旨在某种程度上化解这种愤怒。于是他们做了一些市场研究，发现人们对自动取款机有温暖的感觉，而对加油机则有不好的感觉。所以他们重新设计了加油机，使其看起来更像自动取款机。这样当你在加油机前时，你会觉得自己有一种亲密而温暖的体验，而不是去想自己有多讨厌石油公司。因为我们想要一种符合我们价值观的体验，即使我们正在做的事情并非如此。
99% Invisible is produced by me, Roman Mars, with support from Lunar. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architect, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. Find out more at 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持。它是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。